so when you were a kid there was some
girl in your school and you were not
like a popular guy in school this girl
sandy and when you started telling this
story in the book i was like this is
what [ __ ] lights my fire because this
is what i think inspires most rock and
roll artists what grade were you in
seventh ninth seventh grade seventh
grade okay so sandy's hot
you don't stand a chance with her you
have the balls to go over to sandy and
ask her out and sandy goes yeah
i'll be your girlfriend
and for one glorious week this girl
sandy is your girlfriend as she was my
first love you know so this is the first
time my heart ever felt that feeling
where you see this beautiful girl
and you just you you want her to love
you and you you you want her to be yours
and you know this was the first time i
ever felt this right right and um so
when she uh accepted my offer to be the
future mrs growl she uh
you know i was i was overjoyed i mean
this was the greatest thing that had
ever happened to me now i'd only been
playing guitar for maybe like about two
years or three years so i barely even
knew how to do that right right but i
had posters on my walls and i like had
zeppelin posters and kiss posters and to
me that was like you know that that's
valhalla you know these guys they're
more than human these are like gods and
i want to get one of them you know right
and so
when she told me that she didn't
want to be the future mrs scroll i was
so heartbroken
that i turned to the guitar and so this
was the beginning of that connection
with
my heart and music now i've been
listening to other people's songs about
heartbreak and i'd been listening to
other people's music
you know that that suits their pain but
then now i'm heartbroken i'm like 13
years i was such a skinny [ __ ] nerd
like there was just no way i was ever
going to be one of these people on the
poster or anything like that right in my
mind i was like i'm this is it you know
so i was so heartbroken
that i sort of realized okay the only
way i'm gonna get out of this is to pick
up that guitar and become a [ __ ] rock
star and write songs so now i have a way
to deal with it now i've got a guitar
now i can write songs like that's i
turned my pain and the heartbreak in
that direction but i did have this dream
i had a dream that night where i was on
stage in an arena playing a lead at the
lip of the stage and the audience is
going [ __ ] nuts and i was like you're
[ __ ] amazing and i look down and
she's in the front row crying like right
consumed with regret that she and the
crying made the horrible mistake i've
had the same fantasy the crying is
oh my god i could have been his
girlfriend oh if i had only stayed with
him oh my god i want him so bad and
you're like you know no way i know your
true colors you didn't want me when i
wasn't famous it's just revenge
here's the thing here's the [ __ ] up
thing so then like 25 years later or
something we're playing this hometown
gig
and it's a sold-out show and it's like a
high school reunion everybody i know is
coming to the show it was our first sold
out show in dc arena hometown thing it's
like a homecoming i show up my friend
richie says he's bringing sandy sandy
comes that night i'm on stage
doing a solo at the lip of the stage
audience going you're [ __ ] amazing
and i look down and sandy's right there
just like she was in my dream when i was
13 years old except she wasn't looking
at me crying in regret
she was looking at me laughing saying
you're such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and she gave you the finger
i had told her this story before so she
knew it so as i was as i was sitting
there playing she was looking at me like
don't don't even don't even do it don't
even try like [ __ ] you i'm not gonna cry
over you exactly oh [ __ ] she ruined that
and then and then we've remained friends
over the years in my mind she still
wants you i believe
i'm ready i'm actually reading a book
that was written by sandy right now and
he says
it